well if there was any Marvel character I
was more afraid not to take seriously
than Thor it would definitely be Captain
America not only was his design so silly
with the bright blue the giant bullseye
and the little wings on the side of his
head but there was already a movie made
in the 80s that looked like it was made
in the 70s that big shock was not very
good in fact there's even in this -
Craig review of it so once again I was a
little hesitant to see what they were
gonna do with this
but luckily once again they turned out a
pretty good product
Captain America starts off as a wimpy
little soldier conveyed through some
pretty impressive computer-generated
effects not to say it's flawless but you
gotta look really hard to notice his
good will and courage convinces
everybody that he'd be perfect for a new
experiment one that could lead to a
league of superhumans that could stop
Hitler and his Nazi thugs he agrees to
the experiment and gets turned into a
beefcake but the scientist has killed
thus he's the only super soldier there
is one of the problems though is that
nobody knows what to do with him
he's seen as a hero to many so rather
than actually put him in combat they
just kind of put him in advertisements
Big Show's dance numbers all sorts of
good stuff promoting the good of the war
but he's not really doing that many
heroics finally they agree to send him
into combat and he does a great job that
is until he comes across the evil Red
Skull played by Hugo Weaving
Direction adventures stunts and all
sorts of great effects Captain America
fights off Nazis and saves the day more
times than you can count again not
having read that much Captain America I
didn't really know what to expect from
this bill and I also wasn't really sure
if this was gonna catch on in a market
where we like things they're new and
current and this takes place back in the
40s but through some good writing some
fun stunts and again some very likeable
actors this movie turns out to be a good
adventure yeah I use the word adventure
it's not really as much of an action
don't get me wrong there's lots of
fistfights and great stunts but I don't
know maybe the 40 setting makes me think
a little bit more of like Errol Flynn
and flying planes and spinning around
adventure just feels like the more
proper word the director of this movie
also directed The Rocketeer and it
really shows this guy knows how to make
the time Pierre
look good they also both star very
similar main characters who are not dull
but not the most interesting either but
they're good there's sort of a typical
hero you would see in the 40s very
simple but very likeable naive but
always looking to do good even some of
the typical cliches are played with a
little bit like there's a scene where
this guy grabs this kid and he throws
him in the water trying to escape he's
about to jump in and save the kid but
the kid says no go after him I can swim
God isn't that refreshing the Marvel
movies really do seem to have this great
technique of taking cliches that exist
and either playing with them or only
taking the best aspects of them the ones
most people are tired of they kind of
say yeah we're not doing that we know
you don't like them and we know you
think they're boring so we're only gonna
stick to the ones that are classic
furries and this one does have a lot of
the classics the bad guy with the
disfigured face the triumphant symbols
of America everywhere the heroic stunts
the mad scientist all that good stuff
it's light-hearted but it doesn't steer
away from some heavier moments either
when somebody dies it really feels like
they die and when some characters are
separated by a long distance or even
time you do feel legitimately bad if I
do have one major criticism of the movie
it's with the villain I know it sounds
strange but this is the one thing the
80s film actually did better that is
when they actually showed it through
most of the original film that couldn't
show the Red Skull and he looked pretty
ridiculous but when they did show up he
looked fleshy he looked creepy he had
these beady eyes he had this great voice
Hugo Weaving his fine when he just looks
like a human but then when he rips off
the mask and shows his real face it
looks pretty lame it just looks like a
plastic mask where the other one looked
really juicy the villain as well is kind
of a little dull nothing remember being
like really annoying or stupid or
anything I just don't remember that much
about him that does seem to be the one
weakness of the Marvel films is while
they do a great job portraying the
heroes they don't usually portray the
villains that interestingly I remember
Red Skull was a big bad guy like this
was a really intimidating villain he was
the one Captain America always fought
here he's just kind of like any bad guy
you see in any other movie not
insultingly bad or anything just kind of
standard and part of a hero's journey is
how intimidating the threat is that he's
going up against so the threat isn't
that intimidating you don't get as
invested but like I said he's not
horrible just not anything they're great
but honestly much like Thor this was a
film I didn't think they could really do
I didn't think anybody could take
Captain America seriously but watching
it I actually found myself doing okay
it was clever that they just painted the
wings on the side of his helmet it was
clever the changes that they made to his
outfit and it's even more clever than in
future movies they would update the
outfit to fit the rest of the Avengers
this is a Marvel movie that you can tell
is kind of a segue but unlike Iron Man 2
it feels more natural it stands on its
own as a good movie it has a good
beginning middle and end it has a good
journey
it has good character arts it has good
concerns if the villain was a little
stronger it probably would have stood
out a little bit more but as is it was
once again really impressed I wanted to
know what was gonna happen to Captain
America next after the credits rolled at
this point I was finally realizing
Marvel is really making traditional
comic book movies work they didn't have
to pretend to be anything else or talked
down to you or hide behind anything with
just a few cleverly planned out updates
they were making comic book movies that
comic book fans have always wanted to
see and even better yet they were giving
a wider audience comic book films that
they didn't even know they wanted to see
these films were showing why these
stories were successful why people got
into them why they were worth making
movies about again I'm not gay act like
this was the greatest one or anything
but it is the point where I realized if
you truly embrace a world and an
environment you don't need to make as
many changes as you thought and with the
end credits advertising that the next
big movie was gonna be the Avengers the
ultimate cement of Marvel staying power
was about to take place